bonjour Jean-Louis bollange bonjour
Emmanuel Macron et satisfait de sa
visite aux États-Unis il est convaincu
qu'il a fait prendre conscience au
président Biden que son plan baptisé un
Flashion de réduction Act crée un très
fort déséquilibre entre les industries
américaines et européennes vous avez
accompagné Emmanuel Macron dans son
voyage revenez-vous avec le même
optimisme oh vous savez quand on
accompagne quand on participe à un
voyage on est un peu comme Fabrice le
héros de Stendhal dans les Chartreuse de
palme à Waterloo qui passe toute sa
journée dans la bataille et qui n'y
comprend littéralement rien quand on est
trop près du champ de bataille on ne
voit pas le déroulement des opérations
et effectivement quand on est dans la
suite présidentielle on n'est pas on
n'est pas associé aux entretiens
principaux c'est difficile ce que je
peux dire c'est que en termes de choses
vues comme dirait Victor Hugo la visite
a été un vrai succès je veux dire
c'était très chaleureux très sympathique
très brillant la réception était était
vraiment formidable et personnalité
qu'on a vu oui enfin c'est pas la je
pense que cela ça n'était pas ça
n'aurait pas été comme ça du temps de de
Trump même s'il y avait eu des échanges
des des échanges de de séduction
domination entre Trump et Macron je
crois là il y avait une véritable une
véritable entente sur les valeurs
fondamentales pour répondre plus
précisément à votre question je crois
que il est dans la nature du président
de la République d'être optimiste et
c'est une de ces constantes il est dans
la nature de la mienne d'être pessimiste
donc j'espère que la vérité sera plus
proche de son intuition que de la mienne
je crois que il est certain et Emmanuel
Macron a eu raison de le faire valoir
que
l'inflation relaxation ira comme ils
disent va avoir des conséquences très
préoccupantes pour l'Europe je pense que
Monsieur Bayonne en est conscient cela
dit il faut pas se dissimuler que c'est
l'acte fondamental de politique
économique et de politique tout court de
l'administration démocrate pour
affronter les échéances politiques qui
attendent cette administration dans les
années qui viennent c'est à travers ce
projet qu'on peut qualifier de
protectionnisme ou en tout cas de
subventionnistes à l'égard de
l'industrie américaine c'est à travers
ce projet que les Américains entendent
que les démocrates entendent reconquérir
la classe ouvrière américaine qui s'est
détournée assez massivement de pour
aller vers les républicains trumpistes
et donc les corrections que l'on pourra
faire les corrections auxquelles les les
Américains se prêteront ne seront que
marginales d'où la réponse de de Biden
qui dit bah faites donc
là on se heurte à des contradictions
internes en Europe Emmanuel Macron
précisément défend l'idée lui aussi
d'une forme de protectionnisme européen
est-ce que nous ne sommes pas en train
de reprocher aux États-Unis de faire ce
que nous sommes capable de faire ce qui
est certain c'est qu'on est on est
totalement
versatile nous le peuple français à la
société française sur cette question
parce que quand on était sur la
communauté transatlantique le projet
qu'on avait fait aboutir du temps de
l'administration Obama et que Trump à
torpiller tout il y avait une très très
grande partie de l'opinion publique
notamment à gauche qui disait c'est le
libre-échange c'est la fin on livre
l'économie européenne à l'économie
américaine et maintenant on est dans une
opération contraire où on a
effectivement une un repli
protectionniste qui est quand même un
vrai problème parce que affirmer la
communauté Atlantique sur le plan
politique d'un côté et en même temps la
la
l'isolement une isolation relative de
l'économie américaine il y a pour le
moins une tension alors là on reproche
il faudrait qu'on choisisse mais la
vérité c'est que si nous faisons tous du
protection
c'est un jeu insomnule ça coûtera les
entreprises des deux côtés de
l'Atlantique toucheront de l'argent mais
ça ça devrait s'équilibrer enfin les
seuls les seules personnes qui seraient
exclues de ce jeu seraient les Chinois
ce qu'on recherche effectivement Biden
est-ce que je crois que c'est difficile
de de d'avancer unie sur ce dossier je
ne sais pas je crois que on a on a tout
lieu d'être préoccupé par la phase
actuelle dans laquelle nous sommes
entrés en dans au sein de l'Union
européenne il y a eu après le 24 février
le déclenchement de la guerre d'Ukraine
une véritable solidarité avec notamment
des réactions allemandes qui étaient
très intéressantes et qui montrait que
une vraie volonté tournait la page par
rapport à des attitudes des hermants qui
ont été caractéristiques de l'époque
Merkel dans l'indépendance gazière dans
le refus du nucléaire dans
l'indifférence aux enjeux de défense etc
tout ça a été une première action
aujourd'hui je trouve que ça ne tourne
pas bien ça ne tourne pas bien et les
Allemands le chancelet chaudes ça semble
avoir des difficultés non seulement à
maîtriser sa coalition qui est très
disparate mais même à maîtriser son
propre parti et on a le sentiment qu'il
est dans une tension il veut absolument
maintenir des relations privilégiées
avec la Chine parce que l'implication de
l'économie allemande de l'industrie est
très forte tout en voulant emménager les
Américains qui sont sur une ligne
opposée et il pourrait y avoir un très
mauvais compromis qui consiste à dire je
mets de l'argent moi allemand dans la
défense dans dans le temps et avec cet
argent j'achète du matériel américain
tant pis pour l'industrie de l'armement
d'abord c'est une industrie plus
française qu'a le monde tant pis pour
l'industrie et en revanche je obtiendrai
une certaine complaisance de
l'administration américaine dans mes
rapports avec la Chine je crois que
c'est un calcul très à court terme et et
tout l'enjeu des prochains mois c'est de
dépasser cet antagoniste il y a des
signes positifs notamment l'accord le le
l'accord timide enfin réel sur l'avion
le staff tout ça montre que il y a quand
même de part et d'autre du Rhin une
conscience très aiguë du fait que ce que
nous ne compare ensemble conduira à
notre défaite de part et d'autre un
débat va avoir lieu aujourd'hui un débat
sur l'immigration à l'Assemblée
nationale en prélude au projet de loi
que va défendre le ministre de
l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin ce week-end
Emmanuel Macron a dit parisien que je le
cite un que la France a toujours été une
terre d'immigration cela a-t-il ajouté
fait partie de notre ADN est-ce que ça
vous semble historiquement juste ça me
semble historiquement juste depuis le
début du 19e siècle je pense notamment
que l'industrialisation de la France ça
a été très bien analysé notamment par
Gérard Noiriel dans son dans son livre
sur les ouvriers français le décollage
industriel de la France est fait très
très largement par des immigrés pour une
raison simple les paysans français ont
pris le pouvoir à l'occasion de la
Révolution française et on dit on ne
quitte pas la terre comme ça à la
différence des pays des Britanniques les
agriculteurs britanniques ont été jetés
dans les houyères dans les industries
textiles dans les conditions d'ailleurs
effroyables donc on a eu un
développement de la proto-industrie à
partir de la campagne qui notamment
explique notre succès en matière de luxe
c'était au dixième siècle c'était la
passementerie etc et tout ce qui a été
grande industrie ça a été l'immigration
la Belge sous Louis-Philippe l'italienne
à partir de la fin du compte empire et
sous la Troisième République la
Polonaise après après la guerre
libérique espagnol et portugaise sous de
Gaulle sous de Gaulle d'abord le Maghreb
puis après à partir de Pompidou
l'Afrique noire et donc on a eu une
extension progressive des zones des
bassins
immigrants si je puis dire mais il y a
une relation
intime entre le développement industriel
français et l'immigration là le
président Macron a raison avant on
importait surtout des premiers ministres
comme le cardinal de Mazarin
très rapidement c'est la 29e loi sur
l'immigration depuis 1980 est-ce que ça
n'est pas la preuve qu'on a quand même
bien du mal à traiter ce sujet à
l'attraper par le bon bout bien sûr on
ne sait pas on a un problème de valeur
et un problème de moyens sur le plan des
valeurs on ne sait pas on n'arrive pas à
fixer une doctrine moi je crois que
l'État a la maîtrise doit avoir la
maîtrise de l'immigration c'est pas une
porte ouverte en même temps nous avons
besoin d'accueillir des gens et d'autre
part nous avons une crise générale de
tout le système public qui fait que nous
ne réussissons pas l'assimilation quand
vous combinez les migrations avec une
assimilation non réussie ça donne des
résultats explosifs merci Jean-Luc
bollange bonne journée